okay well welcome my name is Ed Sewell
and on behalf of the Georgetown business
ethics Institute I'd like to welcome all
of you here today I'd like to also
extend a special thanks to ryan conners
he's here for doing the publicity and a
lot of the organization of this event
I'd also like to welcome our viewers
from c-span in addition I want to extend
a very warm Georgetown welcome to
today's speaker who about 25 years ago
opened a single shop in Brighton England
with a business plan that I think a lot
of you business majors in the room would
admire it said this it's best I can tell
it said sell natural cosmetics in
refillable containers tweak it as we go
along very little capital very little if
any industry experience and most
importantly no discernable market for
what she was up to in other words this
business would have resembled the
schematic for a bumblebee a cute little
thing but no way is it going to fly well
it did fly today the body shop operates
out of 1,800 locations it serves 84
million customers which raises the
obvious question why how did that happen
I think the answer lies in a woman who's
going to spend a little bit of time with
us today who did what I would suggest to
you is is arguably the hardest thing
that anybody in business ever undertakes
and that is that she saw a market where
one didn't exist moreover she had the
tenacity of a lunatic to make it real
this doesn't happen very often this is
no small feat but that's not at least
from my standpoint the really important
part of the story the important part I
want to suggest to you is about how she
in the example that that she set in
going about creating this business this
way the example I would offer to you is
is describable as this she's proof
positive that building a business and
making money does not require that we
abandon serious human values now her new
book his title is shown behind me
chronicles both of these stories the
business story the human story and it
does it with a passion that you don't
normally see in CEO literature in fact I
want to suggest to you that this doesn't
qualify a CEO literature because I read
it this weekend and there was not one
instance of chest-pounding
self-congratulatory platitudes in the
entire book what you do get in this book
is you get to go inside the place not
into the boardroom where you usually go
I doubt you guys even have a boardroom
instead you go into what the author
describes as the original core of the
business and of the of the woman whose
life it reflects in philosophy we call
this a soul what you find in there is a
very refreshing hopeful message and it's
my extreme pleasure to introduce today's
off the author of that book Anita
Roddick
um this I love intimacy's and you're so
far away but so bid I know you're gonna
say at the back thinking you can have a
snooze but I'm not going to allow you to
snooze this is not going to be a half
hour of a wannabe business person this
is not going to be one of those tomes
that you see in the book shelves of of
the business world which is five minute
manager one minute management's throwing
everything against awards management
this is powerful stuff I'm talking to
you about this is probably what you're
never being taught in business school
this is talking about fascism within the
financial institutions this talked about
criminality with a major corporations
this talks to you about how you bring
the spirit of your life your culture
your values into the workplace and you
darn well cling on to them because one
of the great lies perpetuated by the
business schools in America followed by
almost every business going around the
world is that the function of business
is to accumulate wealth the function of
business is to garner the profits for
such a few group of people well I
challenge everyone of those precepts and
i'm going to show you rather than just
being rhetorical in the challenges how
i've tried to do it a different way now
i have a slide show which worries me a
bit because i don't think you can see a
thing on there so if anybody's in charge
of dimming the lights please can we dim
the lights so that you can see the
slider don't care about anything else
but this is important because within
five minutes of hearing me you're going
to be bored so here I come out of a two
or three of three months to her around
the world talking about oh my god
business as unusual and I've had I've
been from I've been I've Haddix
wonderful experiences I've been in
Dublin whether true i mean the true
poets and daft as brushes anybody from
Southern Ireland woman came up to me
with six books for me to sign which I
gladly signed until I realized they were
for her cats and then going into some of
the groups as I've traveled in New
Zealand where people are coming up to me
Sal
thousands saying this is the language
this is what we need to hear and why
aren't we hearing it in the media so
first of all you're going to hear a bit
about entrepreneurship but you're never
going to study this in the book in those
in the arm and the annals of this
business books because I think what
you're not being taught about in
entrepreneurs is that when nuts we're
totally crazy that people who are
entrepreneurs have more in common with a
crazy person than they ever have with
anything that you can be taught in
business schools we see visions crazy
people sees visions the only thing that
we do differently is that we can
articulate those visions we cannot stand
hierarchy we cannot manage ourselves out
of a paperback what we are thought
people we've vomit ideas like the genie
in the bottle and have no value at all
in a somebody that's organized in
process can run behind us and galvanize
those ideas and make them work we're
also absolutely obsessional about the
nature of freedom for us our life is
about freedom having a canvas that we
can put our thumb prints on our
thumbprint on and shaping our sense of
balance now the other bizarre thing in
the culture of this country is that we
don't give a toss about money you know
for us the accumulation of wealth is of
no value at all is the cheekiness of
having an idea and pushing it and
pushing and pushing it to see how far it
can go and hopefully the money that you
make by the selling of these products
will actually oil those wheels we never
thought and never still do never think
that business is what it is now 14 as
financial science is about trading it's
about that honorable the oldest form of
exchange the bartering the exchange the
buying and the selling and that magical
place where it works in my case the
shops and hopefully people giving us
some profit for what were their buying
we also never believe that you know life
is no more complicated than love and
work we weren't you or not put on this
plan
let me tell you you will not put on this
planet to keep the economy vital you are
not put on this planet to produce
marketed goods for other people to buy
your put on this planet to learn how to
love to have relationships your
relationship with a cosmology
relationship with a planet your
relationship your understanding your joy
your sense of wonderment and awe that's
what you were put on the planet for and
it is bizarre today when we have
cultures for the first time in our
cultural history the very first time
where economic values have superseded
every other human value so just by
listening to these words you know that I
come on to this platform not as a normal
business person but one as a renegade
business leader a leadership that has
been fashioned totally influenced by the
fact that I'm an activist and an
agitator so in the words of my friend
Gloria Steinem if we come here today and
there's no trouble tomorrow I haven't
done my job or you haven't done your
jobs but I've been in business for some
24 years and with the zealousness of a
religious convert what I've tried to do
is put altruism back on a business
agenda I have found it i am told one of
the world's top brands number 27 i am
told and some of the times it felt
really fraudulent because anything you
do that is instinctive has never seen as
remarkable other times it feels it feels
like management by falling apart at the
seams which I wanted to call the book
but they said no you have to be more
triumphant when you come to America so
the triumph of Anita Roddick galls a bit
when half the time it was you know
running here and there throwing
everything against the wall in seeing
what sticks but I'd look back and I see
what was remarkable in those last 24
years and I'll tell you what it was
while many businesses were pursuing
business as unusual I was part of a very
small different movement that was sort
of alike ideas that were having wings we
were part of a business group of people
not only business people but
first we were part of NJ capitalist
non-government organizations and saw
that business had a different agenda and
it was idealism it was a it was more
about public good than private greed and
I believe and still believe that the
body shop was one of those architects of
that social responsibility in business
movement so we have after 24 years a
proven track record that you can in many
time many times not at the moment many
times keep your financial investors
happy and you can open up 150 shops a
year and you can give back to the
community and you can make great
products and you can open up your doors
and Corral millions of customers
leverage millions of people on issues
that are not ever talked about in the
malls of america or the high streets or
the main streets human rights social
justice environmental issues and
leveraging those customers to come in
and do something about it many of us in
businesses when we travel as i do and
get out of the chair and out of the
office and move we start to have this
growing disquiet about what are these
financial institutions have sort of
bought into and much of what we're
seeing is that there is an enormous
disaster out there and we're seeing for
ourselves that the biggest catastrophe
that all of us have to face is poverty
so some of us see for ourselves what's
going on some of the time like me I go
out to see if i can find ingredients to
build in our products to set up
community trade initiatives sometimes
just to see what is going on and this
was a sign I saw outside of Los Angeles
Airport some years ago by your own I
mean really well-respected Institute
insta installation artist go where
people sleep and see if they're safe and
24 years 24 years ago I traveled through
the great American divide I traveled and
I went through Louisiana Mississippi
Alabama and Georgia to get my first look
at poverty in this country to be poor is
a disaster anyway
but to be poor in this country this land
of so much wealth and plenty is an is an
anomaly I traveled with a vagabond and
I've traveled and I lived every night I
stayed in huts and shacks every night
every day when I visited these shacks I
saw a new shadow economy being being set
up and it was the illegal drug industry
it was unregulated uncontrolled and it
was using a language that we use so
pertinently in business total quality
management that terrorism if ever I
heard also on niche markets quality
product and this was I thought a direct
example as a result of a world that is a
run and controlled by the world by the
globalization this is what happens in
the shadow economy people are living any
life at all trying to live purposeful
life and when capital takes flight and
when corporations move to these passive
and docile workers what are they leave
behind they leave behind toxic wastes
they believe we leave behind embittered
workers and they leave behind more than
anything else a sense of hopelessness
and that was bizarre when years ago we
thought with the civil rights movement
things would be different two weeks ago
before I started on this journey on
talking about business as unusual I
spent a week with a black farmers
federation in Georgia and Alabama and
Mississippi and I went there
specifically to do two things to see
whatever they could grow for us that we
could put in our products and we seen
some really good ideas but also to see
what happens to this almost in
endangered species what happens when you
have an economy of such poverty of
imagination and spiritual poverty that
you have the demise of the black family
farm and nobody gives a toss you have an
endangered species the family farm and
two billion people around the world
living on less than two dollars a day
and nobody cares and I'm wondering as I
as I traveled then and that I travel
through today there are two industries
and actually could
do something about that one is the
alcohol industry and alcohol is always
prevalent high profile in distressed
communities and what it does is really
effective it keeps people's sense of
discontentment which moves into energy
for actually keeps it down it just
dampens it and the other one which was
bizarre and paradoxical was television
almost every home I stayed in 24 hours
what was playing was stupid things like
Hollywood Squares and the rich and
famous in America not using television
as a tool to give people the information
to get out of poverty not using that at
all and that dampens you that dampens
that sense of outrage and yet poverty
which is the real issue is a taboo
subject in this country and is ignored
by the media it's ignored by governments
it's definitely ignored by policymakers
educational programs and it is
definitely ignored in business courses
but i believe it is both foolish and
dangerous to ignore poverty because when
you get act in such a revolting way
people revolt as they did in Seattle I'm
probably one of the few business
international business leaders that
actually was on the side of the
protesters and thanks to the enormously
generous advance of business as unusual
I helped set up a four day program
educational free program that where
every school where every labor union
where every auditorium was opened up for
the people the citizens of Seattle to
hear the story the real story about
economic globalization so I was tear
gassed and I was a baton charge by the
American policeman at that November
protest march last year we were some 700
organizations moving between sixty to
eighty thousand people that took part in
the protests against a World Trade
Organization we were determined we were
educated and we were organized we were
amongst others we were human rights
activists we were battlefield
enemies you know the environmental
groups walking hand-in-hand with the
unions we were religious people
indigenous people labor activists we
were environmentalists workers
grandmothers kids grandfather's mums and
dads we have we had kids dressed as
monic butterflies we had art and
revolution a great group that just made
puppies just just her in a way to just
dampen that sense of aggression we were
totally unprepared as we enter I
reminded me it reminded me when I taught
history years ago when I taught about
the First World War and the first group
of soldiers that left United left
England to fight their war in Flanders
carrying with them their little picnic
baskets thinking oh we'll have a little
war this weekend and then we'll hop home
and that's we were unprepared we weren't
prepared for the tear gas we weren't
prepared we didn't have a handkerchief
soaked with vinegar we didn't put the
toothpaste on and I believes that this
unbelievable right to stand up a citizen
to keep his mouth open the citizen to
rightfully protest if they think their
work within iniquitous organization is
our undeniable right but you listen to
the press now of any people's right or
person's right to protest yorick waiting
it with a word terrorism words create
the world's which contain said words
create the world's and if any form of
outrage or protest in any Street in any
city you are being deemed and criticized
as terrorists let them you remind them
that some of the greatest civil rights
movement some of the greatest human
rights movement some of the greatest
human development in history was a
people's right to stand up in protest so
what was the process about it all came
down to this this was the issue a world
trade system that failed to put human
rights social justice and concern for
the environment at the very core of
every trading relationship that was a
protest in a nutshell all we were
demanding was to make businesses more
thoughtful more respectful more
reflective in short a revolution in
kindness
that's why believe that when you do not
regulate businesses they can become and
they do become criminal this is the
stuff I take personally I take the way
big businesses are shaving away my
sovereign rights I take away personally
my government's total inability to
evolve a corporate code of governance I
take personally when I hold mutated
babies genetically handicapped by toxic
waste and streams and by golly do I take
personally the way businesses can run
ride roughshod over indigenous people
there is not one line one word and get
NAFTA any other economic piece of paper
that protects indigenous peoples
intellectual property rights not one I
take these things personally and I take
really personally the way mrs. azhar
almost totally and utterly moral
indifferent morally and different to
this I remember are being invited to do
a talk a few years back at the
International Chamber of Commerce in
Cancun and I'm invited for a number of
reasons I'm invited because I have a
quote unquote global brand I'm invited
because I'm a token women more often
than not i'm invited because I'm
eloquent and smart and they'll get a
good deal for their money what I never
do is prepare them for what I'm saying
if I did I guarantee or had never been
invited and I have showed them slides of
when I went into the sarawak with a pen
and people who were doing a human
blockade stopping the 24-hour logging by
Mitsubishi and I show them slides of
these indigenous people and I show them
slides of their passivity and I had gone
in just to give monies to you know for
the hyatt cameras and for more time for
food and I remember arriving in secretly
into Sarawak with a pair of deck shoes
and a pair of shorts totally unprepared
for walking 14 hours in Primal
rainforest where every every route is
there to break your neck crossing Ford
ravines of 70 foot high unlocked I
cannot swim I
cannot I cannot I'm frightened of
heights I like my little pillow I like
my shower I am miss middle-class a
middle-aged fearsome but tell it being
being going into this situation it's
it's the experience that change your
values and as I was as I was showing
these slides to the International
Chamber of Commerce I also showed them
slides of the tobacco fields in the weed
with a wheat roll who are indigenous to
the ceramide matter is in in Mexico all
the babies that were being born were
born was no genitalia because of the
pesticides using used in the tobacco
fields now the reaction what was your
reaction hundreds and hundreds of people
there was none there was there was
almost as Gandhi used to refer to it
it's a timid kindness a timidity that
cannot take this outrage this notion of
shame and convert that to action and
that was really chilling for me because
these were the people who could do
something about it these were the
international business people and there
are their their purposes and their work
they can transcend barriers countries
not just on the pursuit of business but
in terms of security in education and
the environment business leaders are the
world's first global citizens and as
such they have such worldwide
capabilities and responsibilities and
our decisions have to be moral decisions
I believe a business comes with no moral
sympathy or honorable code of behavior
then god help us all and if businesses
what used to be the right for
communities to trade equally with each
other is now the right about the license
for the big and the powerful and the
global and the rich to ride roughshod
over any communities or people will have
no choice whether or not they want to
trade so what we have now at this day in
this year and this millennia around the
world we have a new kind of trading
system that acts as a kind of
uncontrollable world government let me
just
sorry I don't do this there we go and it
is the World Trade Organization and it
is a group of totally unelected
officials who run it they are now
effectively the world's highest court
they have the right to overturn any rule
any local law any safety law in my
environment or health if they deem it
interferes with trade it is a blind
government it cannot see anything else
other than the financial bottom line it
cannot see human rights it cannot see
social justice it cannot see protection
of that silent stakeholder the
environment it is a government without a
heart and anytime you have any
organization without a heart you will
see instantly the diminishment of the
human spirit so the massive protests in
Seattle stopped the World Trade
Organization from grabbing some areas of
global power but now that the dust is
settled they're trying it again the
world trade organization wants to give
business to control our basic services
healthcare education water and if they
can't make profits out of the poor then
the poor they'll get the services the
World Trade Organization agreements is
called GATS g 80s and there is a
worldwide campaign building to stop the
ghats catastrophe gat stands for the
general agreement of trade in service it
aims to remove any law or regulation the
restricts profits from the multinational
companies who can make out of selling
services and our services as defined by
the World Trade Organization is quote
this anything you can't drop on your
foot and this covers an amazing array of
160 different service sectors from
healthcare to architecture education to
tourism water supply to waste disposal
and when businesses can roam from
country to country with few restrictions
in search of the most passive and docile
workers were the losers environmental
regulations and the and it had with the
destruction of livelihoods and cultures
the results are
terrifying it is the revival of the
economically fitters and their
interpretation of the fit the marketable
the profitable the sort of global is
pathetically inadequate it's a kind of
fascism really and I'm not overstating
that the financially fit survive those
who don't fit the poor farmers the
marginalized are bled dry it's a
devastating machine that cannot bear any
variation and it will not build the kind
of world I want for my grandkids or my
kids or you want for your future lives I
want I want as many of us do in business
one a financial bottom line that that
includes human rights social Justin and
the environment I want to be penalized
if I make a mess and don't clean up I
don't want to be part of this group of
businesses that go on whining and
whining about ever ever decreasing
standards and looser regulations I don't
want to allow any product coming into my
home likewise your government should not
allow any product coming into this
country or my country that has human
rights or social justice abuses or
sweatshop labor attached to it we should
not allow this to happen it should be on
a moral a moral standard we should say
if our action as a human being could be
corralled and shaped as criminal and
therefore penalized if we did this as a
human being one to the other we should
not allow corporations to act the same
so however I am hopeful I'm Italian and
optimistic than when have you ever met a
miserable Italian you've probably met
them venal and you probably have seen
them self-absorbed and highly terrifying
in many ways but you've never met a dull
Italian and my two areas of Hope is this
my first hope is that you have a new
kind of customer out there one that's
acting more like an ethical watchdog
than a hungry consumer and they are a
growing movement of people and hopefully
many of you here who are choosing not to
buy from come
and is when you know the story behind
their products and there are also saying
they do not want to buy anything that
has child labor or sweatshop labor
unless they have proof that the
government that the coal corporations
are actually working to build conditions
of safety and health within that within
the factories I choose not to buy from
certain genes manufacturers I know the
story I choose not to buy from coal I
choose not to buy from walmart I make my
choices I choose not to buy from total
because of their business practices in
in Burma or unocal or Nigeria in shell
of their practices in Nigeria I make my
choices now what does that make me that
makes me this a vigilante consumer and I
believe nobody here in marketing or
business should ever underestimate this
power of the vigilante consumer because
our activities are going a long way
further than just simply refusing to buy
we are campaigning funding and
advocating for change no company can
afford to ignore these vigilante
consumers remember a few years ago about
the consumer assaults on lore'l in
gillette on the animal rights on the
animal rights issue within the cosmetic
industry now they are being joined
together by the human rights Lobby who
are joining belly-to-belly with the
ethical investors consumer boycotters
direct action specialists who are
spotting these so-called business agenda
and therefore in my view rightly making
business not government business a
target of protests and then this is
something you're not being taught about
in the media there is this enormous new
community movement the rise of the NGOs
the non-government organizations who
were once a small band of charities
raising money for the poor in Africa
I've grown into the one of the most
vastly influential sectors in this world
when I was in Seattle I was talking to
UM I was talking to a shell official and
he said to me this he said we don't fear
restriction or regulations anymore what
we fear
is what we fear is consumer revolt one
question from Greenpeace was by facts
not even a threat by facts forced a man
food manufacturer in 1999 to take out
all the genetically modified ingredients
out of baby food one fax it was
Indonesian non-government organizations
that helped bring down a dictator
president suharto so there's my one ray
of hope this growing popular movement of
ethical consumers alongside this huge
growth of the non-government
organization now my second hope is this
community trade I believe if governments
or global planning economic institutions
are to help they have to put the poor
first as active participants as advisors
and leaders and any institution that
mobilizes is grassroots is a light at
the end of the tunnel because the only
true experts on poverty of the poor so
as a result i'm a passionate believer in
small-scale economic initiatives now
many of you here may think viewed in
isolation get a life these aren't that
big you know a few women digging or guys
digging a well in africa few women
planting trees and india an old guy
teaching kids up in a peruvian mountain
how to read but if you if you take it
from a global perspective their their
impact and scale is enormous it's almost
like closing your eyes and seeing this
vast like rag tag line of grassroots
organizations are circling the globe
pushing back environmental regulation
and keeping communities intact and i'd
give you a couple of examples of what we
do in my company the body shop we have a
we have a real belief in setting up and
establishing cooperatives working
alongside fair trade associations where
we have a special purchasing product
purchasing process where we buy directly
from them from the community few years
ago I was visiting Ghana and looking at
the shea butter cooperatives they're all
groups of farmers who had grown share
butter & Co
a butter I love ghana ghana has gone was
magical as a West Country African
country Ghana is worth mostly
matrilineal on information and knowledge
passes through the woman when a young
girl is born she's raised to the heavens
and the village celebrates giving you
know swades of cloths and food and fruit
little boy is born in so well after work
we go but also within in ghana they have
such a notion of our beauty that
actually baffles anybody in the West and
likewise they're baffled by Western
notion of perfection physical perfection
they can't quite understand why we ought
to all need to look like a coat hanger
where they have a belief that to be
beautiful you have to be as rotund and
as magnificent as the mountains and the
valleys and actually to be really
beautiful you have to walk like your bum
is chewing gum so I'm a great sympathy
with garne and women and gunning notion
of beauty so going though we saw Coco
but we saw cocoa butter and sharon are
and what we do is we then put it
directly into our products I make I'm a
company that makes thousands of skincare
products they are not the body and blood
of Jesus Christ there are mullins their
potions their lotions all they do is
clean polish and protect there are no
values inherent within a skincare
product no values not the value of life
or joy or celebration or so my my
attention to myself over the years was
how do you bring a value stream into a
into a product line that is essentially
not valuable I mean it's not it's not
food it's not it's not medicine and I've
found one or two ways and one of the
most one of the most effective way is to
look that it up for ingredients where
you go into the past and use it as a
prologue for ideas and you buy those
ingredients directly from cooperatives
or fair trade associations that work
directly within the communities mostly
in the developing world and we have some
nearly 39 suppliers in 20 countries and
there are a formal groups cooperatives
or fair trade associations so we work
with some
thousand families and that doesn't
include the thousands and thousands of
families that benefit from the education
the information on HIV and AIDS
awareness for clinics and fresh water so
we put these these issues out in our
trucks and we celebrate that because we
don't know what else to do with our
tracks putting body shop skin and hair
care is pretty boring but by themselves
these initiatives will not transform the
global economy but what they do is
transformed my company's way of doing
business they think that about
responsibility and about how you
humanize that process of doing trade and
I would rather let me tell you hand on
heart I would rather be measured for the
numbers of community trade projects I
have then ever be measured by the
various or the variations of my share
price then let me tell you another one
which is in southern India in Tamil Nadu
which has been the poorest one of the
poorest states and what they have you
find in that area of acacia trees which
they used to cut down for firewood what
we're doing now is cutting down just the
branches and with some very simple wood
turning have make these millions of
wooden massage rollers for us so 500
people are employed in this campus they
are mostly predominantly female workers
which were previously unskilled
agricultural workers they're employed on
a casual basis usually with no security
so that there's no car system and what
they've done with these thousands and
thousands of products that they make for
us first thing they do is they build a
school 190 kids in this montessori
school kids then we bring in the
disabled kids we also bring in we also
bring our teachers take our teachers
into terror mangalam and teach the kids
in the sweatshops in the matchbox
factories and we also have a brilliant
brilliant program to teach women in the
sex industry out of that profession into
another one they have a veterinary
clinic build in Teddy and Teddy campus
17,000 livestock were cured were treated
and we have the or they have the best
HIV and
awareness program which is directed as a
clinic sexually transmitted a the clinic
right by a gas station is truck drivers
a pass on aids in India and so we have
the condoms we have freely given we have
the videos on play we have the doctors
doing the examinations and when the
truck is parked their vehicles and wait
for the gas tanks to fill up they
usually take women over well over a wall
and have their way that's when our merry
band band of young medics jump over the
wall tap them on the shoulder offer them
a free condom the best form of coitus
interruptus in southern india and it
works now compare this to the one of the
biggest most powerful multinational in
nigeria let me just put this in ah let
me do this where billions of dollars of
profits are made for the company
shareholders where billions of barrels
of oil are extracted out of an area
called agony land in this in the rivet
state where 500,000 unrepresented people
in a nation I have no the teachers the
nation's used to be the nation's
Nigeria's teachers and poets and writers
have never received one penny back in
compensation of the oil drilled in that
land everywhere I traveled when i was
there in november there were oil flares
everywhere it's much cheaper is much
easier to let these gas affect the
respiratory system of young kids and it
is to patch it up is too expensive or
look at this one this is the because
you'd go around into the various
kingdoms as you pass as you pass the
through the you know the villagers oil
seeping all through the villages or this
one as you go into the schools to how
the kids are making their deaths are now
they'd fashioning on the walls with
glitz letters this used to be the
nation's teachers and writers and poets
or look at this one this is a hospital i
visited and took this photograph where
50,000 people are looked after so called
where women were having cesareans
without any honest
attic and where you could open up a
refrigerator and finds three or four
serums end of story tell me about this
does it move your spirit does it send
you into a sense of this is outrageous
decide I want to be part of the system
that in a way institutionalizes is
business thinking is this right is this
criminal behavior is this of such low
standard in our sense of what is right
and just wherever religion you come from
Christianity Buddhism Judaism Islam
isn't this outrageous but this is the
way we do business and when I'm asked by
the media consistently but how can you
run tell me this how can you run a
ethical company and still be profitable
just just turn this word around let's
deconstruct it let's move that sentence
around does that mean then to be
profitable you have to be unethical
which means rapacious lie cheat steal
well what about this what about the
Quakers a century and a half ago you
know some of your its greatest business
people most successful religious never
stole never took out more money than
what they put in my golly doesn't that
say a lot to shame some of the CEOs in
this country without seeing compensation
packages and they looked after their
stakeholder the community of the
workforce they built homes for them a
bit schools for them they cared about
them you couldn't find a child
development center you know in this
country maybe one in Patagonia but I've
never seen a child development center
attached to the workplace what about the
protection this is de rigueur and now in
business so for me when we were asked by
Ken Sara we were some years back to pro
helped raise the awareness in our shops
and our hundreds of shops we had around
the world to raise this issue on the
plight of the Ogoni people which we did
we turned our shops into action stations
those that we had extra rooms this as a
shop in Boulder Colorado and we put
information on the plight of the Ogoni
and the shell we had we had fax machine
so our customers and our staff could fax
directly not only shell but also their
goalie people to support them also
Nigerian embassy and we actually allowed
our staff up to pick it to pick at the
Nigerian embassy and to picket shell
previous to ken Sarah we were being
judiciously murdered by the then
despotic government no idea how do you
allow this to happen people say but
there what's this to do with making skin
care it has everything to do with
developing the human spirit within the
confines and the protection of a
workplace we do not have an educational
system that polishes this notion of
wonderment and awe and social justice
and compassion this notion of compassion
is caring for the week in the fryer we
don't have it in our educational system
what we have in our educational system
is training young people to be
consistently passive and dose I'll come
down that conveyor belt to get a job and
guess what there's rarely jobs at the
end of it this is not a job creation
economy this is a a wealth creating
economy and then a lot of people said to
me this is this is not what business is
about this is everything about having a
monday to friday living rather than a
monday to friday death this is about
punishing this human spirit and this is
about the protection in your daily work
that you're allowed to do this and
you're educated beyond the education of
how to make a widget work faster so we
call this the politics of consciousness
and many people many certainly financial
and people would say mmm-hmm this is
you're really stupid doing this stuff
this is not what we should be about and
I think maybe what people call a stupid
i think is fearless and i have to say I
campaigns are really Dean bad either
brave or either stupid and because there
is a consistent drop in sailed whenever
we advertise through our shop windows
any of these companies issues human
rights social justice voter registration
or whatever there is a drop you know so
what there's a drop that's why companies
never copy us and that's why this is not
cause related marketing but I wish the
golly the four million people that came
into our shops in England to change the
law in England on the issue of annum
testing within the cosmetic industry had
also bought a product that would have
been really cool or the 12 million
people that banded together around the
world on supporting our human rights
defenders would make your mark 12
million people put their thumbprint on
defending human rights that does not
translate to guess what 12 million
people buying body butters not wish it
could but it isn't and it's I think this
ingenious to think that this type of
work on marketing issues is about
getting and corralling your customers to
buy more products so this notion of
politics of consciousness is starting to
bubble up in America it's starting to
bubble up in there in there and
certainly in the in the universities and
it is this issue that is causing more in
more outrage than any other issue no
where is the public outrage displayed
more than in this reaction to child
labor we have ample proof that the worst
forms of child labor children are being
used and as slaves they are bought their
soul they are tortured they are confined
to the workplace and they aren't able to
leave their jobs whether it's kids
working in a brick kiln or whether it's
working as a bonded farm laborer or kids
in sexual slavery being used as human
cargo for sexual purposes and when you
see this huge rise in the tourist
industry the dark side the shadow side
is prostitution child prostitution
you'll find like countries like Thailand
there are now more prostitutes than
there are monks this is a direct
mentality that puts economic values
overriding every other human value and
this is a direct mentality where
countries governments government leaders
are no longer measuring their their
their strength measuring their strength
by how they look after the weak and the
frail so for me I believe that what we
have to do in business now is to show
more developed emotions in fear and
greed I take this
please God you take this personally we
have to make sure that companies and
products or service at rest selling and
people are buying show more developed
emotion we have to also make sure that
thousands of people who are working and
they're due in the disciplines of
marketing and advertising take their
mark vast reserves of creative gift to
be able to do something to break their
to raise this with this notion up and to
let people have this understanding
because this is not talked about this is
not talked about in many of the
newspapers is what it does it's fashions
and shapes maybe a loss of revenue into
in terms of their advertising when it
comes down to sort of interpretation of
social problems within the arena of the
beauty business the body shop has had
some fun and for me it's a lot to do
with this graphic design and i love the
ancient art of of illustration and
graphic design and I've always managed
to elicit as some fun from it and so let
me show you a couple of examples of how
we've had some fun with the art of
descent we put a really generously
proportioned doll called Ruby short for
rubenesque and our windows in 1998 and
that was supposed to remind people of
the beauties about confidence it was
about self-esteem and I know many of you
think orders that wishy-washy subject is
not self esteem is the route to
revolution it is let me tell you it's
about self-knowledge self-worth is
political activism this is not something
about people's absorption with ourselves
so we had some really interesting
information from America which was when
young kids young girls open up a fashion
magazine that instantly depressed and
though you had countries like Argentina
where some seventy percent of all young
girls are anorexic under the age of
fourteen or bulimic a big disaster this
and and the industry has been propelling
it for years the beauty and the fashion
industry because they're really smart
it's a strategy that's worked which is
basically alienate young women from
their bodies control their minds and
your bodies in your control their minds
you control their minds and guess what
you can control what they buy and if you
take a look at any of the messages
within the beauty of fashion industry
the repeated message is mostly shut up
facelift and diet and oh by the way if
you have crews feeds and dimples on your
thighs then on to the trash heap of life
Hugo this is a continued message and it
is and maybe an oversimplification but
it is dangerous and it is immature and
is and it works so we come up with ruby
and ruby was we thought was fabulous so
we had a vacationer campaign within
weeks we had a very serious letter from
Mattel who told us to cease and desist
because to quote we were being
disrespectful to Barbie so we changed
her to this let me see if she's here and
we immediately got into trouble in the
mass transit of Hong Kong they said this
was offensive and one of the malls in
Chicago told us to take it down because
it was pornographic I have to say when
you're sitting next to make a stop site
victoria secrets this is pornographic so
maybe business has to take a bit more
responsibility maybe if we don't have an
educational system that challenges what
we're being what we're seeing or what
we're hearing or what we're reading it
doesn't challenge the language of the
ads maybe if it doesn't challenge in any
book in any school and i don't know
about the high schools in this country
but do they ever sit down and talk about
ethics instead of something really
boring like what happens with a bit of
corruption going on here a bit of
bribery here the real issues of social
alienation and and poverty and you know
just no jobs they talk about that well
enough in the ethics classes the
consumers we have what we have is the
french would describe a bourgeois
society where the wealthy are now
shaping everything we see that in the
gated communities we see that in
celebrity and entertainment obsession I
don't know what we're lacking we're
lacking a sense of what we're lacking is
a diminishment of the human spirit and I
somehow got an answer to this and it's
about something in my own life I know
wealth came to me too late it came to me
in my early 40s so I was shaped as an
active as well before that decades and
decades before
of that but I know one thing that
happens when well hits you it corrodes
your human spirit it diminish your sense
of empathy with a human condition that's
what it does like it or not it happens
no matter how much you can say your
philanthropic it happens we don't have
an understanding or a care we pass the
poor in the street we don't act as
Christians should do I protecting the
weak in the frail so I think with this
ever-increasing wealth which we have for
a certain level of people in our
societies that diminishment is happening
that sense of no longer an outrage
outrage is no longer de rigueur sense of
sense of changing the way things are
getting out when did we last stand up
and stand up and protest what would we
protest for what would be the things to
take a wealthy comfortable person to
stand up a protest maybe what this
always a reflection and this election
where the biggest reaction to them to
the inaugural speech which I thought was
charming in many ways was this reaction
to the loss of tackle the lack or the
you know the the lessening of taxes it's
all about the self so the rugged
individualism that Bush and Reagan and
Thatcher had has not translated I
believe to community thinking or
community care so I would I because I'm
just see the enemy out then I would say
there's more responsibility in business
because I think more than any other
institution they are more powerful now
and the consumers or the customers and
why call em consumers I've tried to ban
that word in my company can't we just
call an old-fashioned more like
customers why not just say human beings
and see what we think about but this
notion of that we were put on this earth
just too consumed by this repetition of
the word yeah education has to be moral
education but is it going to happen
probably not yes sir
my name is Tom tripper cabbage I'm a
senior in the undergraduate business
school I was wondering how you propose
dealing with the opportunity cost of
changing the media for example the Super
Bowl a commercial 30 second commercial
cost two million dollars in the United
Way was all over that spending millions
of dollars i assume maybe they were
allowed a small price but the
opportunity cost of changing the media
as opposed to putting that money towards
good well i think what you'd be really
agreed to look at as guerrilla marketing
for groups you know getting I you take a
look you take a look when people shop
they never shop with their eyes like
that or they never shop with their eyes
they shop with their eyes to the ground
they won't making sure that would tread
on something I think a real atactic
putting things on pavements putting
things on wall fly posting I think you
know when we have a look at these big
media opportunities so-called which is
why your your your election how many
billions of dollars were spent in
marketing in advertising and the medians
in the television two billion dollars I
mean what could we've done with
education I could have taken that down
to the black farmers federation in a
nanosecond I don't know how you change
that I think it's happening very much
with certain TV ads who's known i'm
sitting in a friend's house last night
and I'm just zapping I don't wanna watch
one don't add because they're dull I
read ads in if you've ever seen that
wonderful magazine called what's the one
in Canada at Buster's have you ever seen
ad Buster's any of you in marketing have
to buy at Buster's so I don't know the
answer to that other than guerrilla
tactics people just not wanting to watch
I think the biggest obscenity in
advertising now is the billboards the
I've got we work in average you know
marketing group in San Francisco the
entire skylines of san francis who've
gone is billboards it's gap city it's
nike city and their civil space that's
being taken up by ads people are
outraged Naomi Klein says it in a book
no logo people no longer want this civil
space to be taken over by brands and
there is a brand war out there people
don't want bigness they want high
profile in the community there
want to know the business is doing
something good but they just don't want
their civil space being taken over so
have you any ideas oh come on
intervention reducing the cost may be
providing subsidized wouldn't it be
great if the government said hey
wouldn't it be great if one city I wish
it was Santa Barbara where I live that
said no more ads we're just going to
have aphorisms poetry quotes from kids
just you know this notion of you know
like Jenny haasan's thing go where
people sleep and see if they say just a
just a jog people sense a compassion
wouldn't that look amazing if we had
poetry poetry on the subways poetry on
the on the billboards anyway that's not
going to happen but it's a nice thought
anymore well thank you very oh yes one
more yes sorry okay thank you very much
that was a very good speech thank you
just um well you said that you were
optimistic about student-led
demonstrations and you're right they do
have a voice but the one thing that did
they do not have his money and you know
companies like body shop and others
there in the front of a moral business
practices is there a coalition is there
anything that they are doing to support
such movements or is their proposals
towards other organizations that are
illiquid that have elected officials and
not organizations like the WTO or I'm F
etc there are this two or three
organizations in this country which are
starting to have more of an edge to them
businesses for social responsibility
which was a arm that came out of Social
Venture network which are a group of
business philanthropists philanthropist
social entrepreneurs businesses NGOs
really coming together with a remit to
making businesses more thoughtful and a
profound organization that is and
learning a lot from their business
practices in Scandinavian primarily
there's also really good groups like the
International Forum on globalization but
these are non-government organization
groups there isn't really the direct
response to the Chamber of Commerce
which are actually the processes of the
World Trade Organization in many ways I
would say would be the corporate
responsibility groups like the you know
businesses for social responsibility but
in terms of networking we work when we
tending to network across with strategic
alliances we're tending more now not to
network with other businesses so much as
learning from non-government
organizations or learning from public
policy and really some of the most
profound thinking is being done by
government practices in Scandinavia and
we're also looking to the past you know
one of the things that gives this
movement credibility is the historic
imperative and you know you can't argue
when I'm when a when a somebody from
business talk to me about you know
maximizing profits and I can quote you
know Queen Elizabeth the first and 15
something or other when she only gave
her her the merchants the right to trade
in England if they gave a really big
percentage back to the community and
that was 500 years ago so there's lots
of ways that we can Corral I think a
sense of a sense of authenticity about
this movement the most important thing
though is to change language the
language is pivotal so we have got to
stop allowing and Kennedy said it's so
brilliantly he said they the opposite to
the lie the opposite to truth is not the
lie deliberate and provoked it is it is
is almost it's it's the ability to take
these and he didn't say this because I'm
paraphrasing it's the myth taking the
myth and that which is considered to be
truth by repetition that's what has to
happen and when you talk about
consistently in the business world we
have to maximize our profits we have to
make some I process the business of
businesses to financial financial
resource what we got to challenge and
when we take words like from the words
and the language of accountancy or
economics and economics are a really
eerie thing when I was a kid at
economics or economists were professions
now suddenly they've metamorphosed
enters into science
and nobody ever challenges scientists
and you take the words the language of
economics and see how it comes into our
language of relationships like how long
have you invested in this relationship
now what if we took the words of
metaphysics of the words of poetry or
the words of of care or love or whatever
and put segue that into the business
lexicon I wonder what would happen and
how that would validate a new business
way of thinking but we have to we have
to first of all I think finally
challenge everything we were taught in
business school everything you're taught
as a valuable way of doing business you
have to keep your spirits so polished
you have to keep your sense of challenge
so polish and then you have to
absolutely believe that for the time in
your life that you're in business which
is most of your creative actions where
you build some of your biggest
friendships and relationships that you
keep the spirit the spirit of
responsibility and the divine spirit of
what makes you a human being human you
have to protect that because it is there
totally totally to take it away and
that's not business cause that is
business as we are seeing it now in this
century thank you